But um...
So, if you guys do not know, for those new here, I am not a singer.
I am a terrible singer.
This is like a little warning, a little disclaimer for those of you who don't want to have their ears bleed out.
I am not very good at singing, but this year, my resolution, I'm starting singing lessons this year.
Let's go.
It's jazz time guys.
It's time to jazz.
Wherever I roam, I couldn't be fonder of my big home.
The bees are buzzing in the trees to make some honey just for me.
Then you look under the rocks and plants and take a glance at a fancy ant.
Then maybe try a few.
The bare necessities of life will come to you.
They'll come to you.
Look for them.
The bare necessities.
The simple bare necessities.
Forget about your worries and your strife.
I mean the bare necessities.
That's why a bare can rest at ease.
With just the bare necessities of life.
Now when you pick a paw paw, or a prickly pear, and you prick a raw paw, well next time, beware.
Don't pick the prickly pear by the paw.
When you pick a pear, try to use the claw.
But you don't need to use the claw when you pick a pear with a big paw paw.
Have I given you a clue?
I don't even know what the fuck I'm saying.
The bare necessities of life will come to you.
They'll come to you.
Yo, it's jazz!
Jazz solo!
Buh dum buh dum buh dum.
Buh dum buh dum.
Oh shit!
Maracas time!
Woo!
Maracas!
I'm jazzing!
Oh!
Oh man, this is really living.
So...
Try and relax.
Yeah...
Cool it.
Fall apart in my backyard.
Cause let me tell you something, little britches.
If you act like that bee's acting, uh uh.
You're working too hard.
And don't spend your time looking around...
for something you want...
that can be found.
When you find out...
you can live without and go along.
Not thinking about and tell you something true.
The bare necessities of life will come to you.
Woo!
Look for the bare necessities.
The simple life.
Bare necessities.
Forget about your worries and your strife.
I mean the bare necessities.
That's why a bear can rest at ease.
With just the bare necessities of life.
Woo!
Jazz!
And that's how you jazz guys.
That's how you fucking jazz.
Alright, that's why I told you guys.
I'm very bad at singing.
That is...
This is the first song.
The first song of the...
of the year.
And we're not gonna have a song...
until I get better at singing.
Thank you everyone.
We're listening.
Hahaha!
Thank you desktop.
Sh